iconic lakes and reservoirs have been
drying up in recent years but are these
losses in specific regions or a global
trend
a group of hydrologists created a first
of its kind data set to see how water
storage is changed in the world's
largest lakes and what might be driving
these transformations
since only a limited number of lakes
across the world have long-term
on-the-ground measurements the
researchers turned to satellite data
[Music]
using almost a quarter million images
from NASA's landsat satellites they
calculated the surface area of lakes
over time they were even able to use
images partially obscured by clouds by
calculating margins using other
cloud-free images
next the researchers needed to see how
the changes in surface area related to
lake levels
for this they mostly turn to water
levels taken by altimeters instruments
aboard satellites that determine water
level by measuring the time it takes for
radar or laser pulses to reach the
ground and bounce back
most of the largest lakes had altimetry
data for the entire study period others
had lake level data for a limited period
of time or depth profiles in order to
see how storage changed over time they
created a hypsometric curve for each
Lake this shows the relationship between
surface area and lake level
the area underneath two points on the
curve shows the change in water volume
after analyzing nearly 2 000 Lakes the
researchers found a net decrease of
about 22 billion tons of water storage
per year between 1992 and 2020.
that's equivalent to all the water used
in the U.S in 2015 or 17 times the peak
volume of the biggest Reservoir in the
U.S Lake Mead
when we look overall across all
lakes and reservoirs we found that more
than half of those were seeing declining
trends
we were surprised about the degree and
to which
Lakes actually personally we find some
signals from Sanctuary reasons such as
the western United States but now even
for the human regions were also
identified by spread Liquid Star
declines over this period
based on these declines they found
they found a global population lives in
an area that feeds water into a
declining Lake each white pixel on the
map represents about 5 000 impacted
people
but there were some lakes and reservoirs
that did experience increases in water
storage this increasing liquid study
Trends are largely find in the inner
Tibetan plate Hall
or under populated Northern Great plants
in North America
they also found that reservoirs as a
whole increased in water storage mainly
from new reservoirs built between 1992
and 2020. but in many other places we
were seeing Reservoir water declining
reservoirs can lose water storage
through sedimentation when water sits
around in the reservoir a lot of the
fine particles will essentially be
deposited and so you actually are
essentially making the reservoir Lake
shallower and shallower
after establishing how Lake water
storage changed over time the
researchers tackled what could be
driving these changes
they focused on natural lakes since
there aren't global data on Dam
regulation which heavily influences
Reservoir levels they looked at five
potential drivers temperature
precipitation water runoff from
surrounding areas human water
consumption and potential
evapotranspiration how much water the
atmosphere can absorb from the Earth's
surface
they then created models using different
combinations of data sets related to
these variables from their analysis more
than half of the losses from natural
lakes could be partially attributed to
climate change this included Lakes
declining from increases in potential
evapotranspiration and temperature as
well as some decreases in runoff
there were also declines driven by human
water consumption that were previously
undocumented like in the Salton Sea and
Lake March Akita
nestled among these declines were some
stories of successful water conservation
for example Lake Savon in Armenia
recovered water storage after passing a
law to limit water withdrawals for
irrigation
opportunities to not only study
large lakes but also the smallest which
might be more locally important in some
regions
missions like the surface water and
ocean topography satellite which can
measure Lakes just one hectare in size
will be key to ongoing observations that
can inform how to Grapple with declining
Lakes
thank you